Alright people, we're taking a break from
politics this week and focusing on the F word,
that's right, Food.
They say you are what you eat and if that's
true, a lot of us are half hot dog, half pizza
and half ice cream.
I know that's three halves but we're a pretty
fat bunch of people these days.
Every week there's a new diet to follow, a
new oil to avoid, or a new super food that'll
change you life.
Then the week after that, we usually find
out this new revolutionary diet will actually
made you gain weight, you actually need that
oil to live, and the super food does absolutely
nothing.
Add an endless slew of magazines to the countless
websites and blogs devoted to keeping you
clicking on the newest fad and it becomes
almost impossible to figure out what you should
eat.
As those of you who follow me on social media
know, I'm in the midst of a little diet myself
right now.
I'm doing a slow-carb paleo diet which is
a slightly modified version of what former
Rubin Report guest Tim Ferris helped popularize.
Basically I'm eating only meat, fish, and
veggies, with no sugar and very limited carbs.
I'm even putting grass fed butter in my coffee
to get an extra boost of fat and energy in
the morning.
As of taping this Direct Message, I've lost
about 5 pounds in 10 days.
I've also punched 4 random strangers on the
street for looking at me the wrong way...but
as they say, everything in moderation.
Of course what you should or shouldn't put
in your body isn't just about weight.
It's also about your mind.
And this is a place where the science is actually
pretty solid.
The foods we eat, or don't eat, can have a
tremendous affect on our brain itself, right
down to our ability to think.
As we've seen a spike in degenerative brains
diseases such as Alzheimers and Parkinson's
Disease, which are just two of the many forms
of dementia, it's becoming clearer and clearer
that fueling our brains with the right foods
and avoiding the wrong ones are a key to brain
health.
So much of what we talk about on this show
is related to to clear and critical thinking.
While we may not think about how food is affecting
our brains on a daily basis, feeding our brains
the right foods as as important, actually
probably more important than feeding our brains
the right information.
So this week we're gonna learn some information
on what we should feed our brains so that
we're optimized to engage in intellectual
battles in the best way possible.
Joining me to discuss this is an old friend
of the show and author of the new book Genius
Foods, Max Lugavere.
Now excuse me while I put grass fed butter
on an avocado sprinkled with goji berries